This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantantham. Depending on when you were born, you might have a special reaction to some of these songs. What it sounds like, we know no it's crying. I wanna, I wanna, I wanna, I wanna, I wanna really, really, really wanna say, Because it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it for granted that nostalgia is an ordinary, harmless emotion. Nobody thinks you should go to a therapist for posting a photo from your childhood with a hashtag throwback Thursday, or if you have a weak spot for fruit loops or lucky charms. But that's a relatively new way of thinking. It started out very much as being considered a disease. And people even today, a lot of people will say,
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。根据你的出生年代，你可能对其中一些歌曲有特殊的反应。听起来，我们知道那是在哭泣。我想，我想，我想，我想，我想，真的，真的，真的想说，因为它是，它是，它是……（此处省略重复词）……理所当然地认为怀旧是一种普通且无害的情绪。没人会觉得因为你在“怀旧星期四”发布了一张童年照片，或者因为你对水果圈麦片或幸运符麦片情有独钟，就该去看心理医生。但那是一种相对较新的思维方式。它最初被认为是一种疾病。即使在今天，很多人仍然会说，
well, I'm not nostalgic because I think about the future. Today on Hidden Brain, what exactly is nostalgia? And can nostalgia help us move forward in life? Or does it simply leave us stuck in the past? Clay Rutledge is a psychology professor at Nauticoa State University. He's the author of Nostalgia, a psychological resource. Clay, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. In your book you describe the origin of the word Nostalgia, you say that in the 17th century,
嗯，我不怀旧，因为我思考的是未来。今天在《Hidden Brain》节目中，怀旧究竟是什么？怀旧能帮助我们继续前行吗？还是它只会让我们困在过去？克莱·拉特利奇是北达科他州立大学的心理学教授。他是《怀旧：一种心理资源》一书的作者。克莱，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你邀请我。在你的书中，你描述了“怀旧”（Nostalgia）这个词的起源，你说在17世纪，
a medical student noticed that Swiss soldiers fighting in the plains of Europe were experiencing a set of emotions and physical symptoms. Other physicians ran with this idea and they thought nostalgia was a condition unique to Swiss soldiers. They believe that the endless clanging of cowbells in the Alps triggered some kind of trauma to the brain. Yeah, so there was a medical student named Johannes Hofer and be coined this term Nostalgia, which he described as a cerebral disease of demonic cause that originated from continuous vibrations of animal spirits
一位医学生注意到，在欧洲平原作战的瑞士士兵经历了一系列的情绪和生理症状。其他医生采纳了这个想法，他们认为怀旧是瑞士士兵特有的一种疾病。他们相信阿尔卑斯山无休止的牛铃声对大脑造成了某种创伤。是的，当时有一位名叫约翰内斯·霍弗的医学生创造了“怀旧”这个词，他将其描述为一种由恶魔引起的脑部疾病，源于动物精神在
throughout the middle brain. That's basically the beginning of the term Nostalgia. Of course, that doesn't mean that was the first time people ever experienced it or even noticed it, but that was really the genesis of the study of nostalgia. So we've obviously come a long way since those early conceptions of nostalgia, and you say that some of the people who have led the way were not researchers, but marketers? Yeah, I mean, that's one of the things that I think is really fascinating about this story, not just of what nostalgia is, but the history of how people explored it is on the one hand in
中脑的持续振动。这基本上就是“怀旧”一词的开端。当然，这并不意味着那是人们第一次经历或注意到这种情绪，但这确实是怀旧研究的起源。显然，自那些对怀旧的早期概念以来，我们已经取得了长足的进步，你说过，引领这一领域的人中，有些并不是研究人员，而是营销人员？是的，我的意思是，我认为关于这个故事最迷人的一点，不仅在于怀旧是什么，还在于人们探索它的历史，一方面在
the early years of scholarship on the Stahlges. We just discussed there was this very disease-focused model, and then fast-forward to the 1980s, which of course were going from the late 1600s to the 1980s, which of course were going from the late 1600s to the 1980s, and you see this more commercial driven or marketing or advertisement focused approach to nostalgia, which of course would paint a completely different picture of nostalgia because marketers don't think that people buy products that make them miserable. They think people buy products that they enjoy and that make them happy. Parents love to tell about when they were kids. It's called the Falcons.
怀旧研究的早期，正如我们刚才讨论的，存在一种非常以疾病为中心的模式，然后快进到20世纪80年代——当然，我们从17世纪末一直跨越到20世纪80年代——你会看到一种更具商业驱动或以营销广告为导向的怀旧方法，这当然会描绘出一幅完全不同的怀旧图景，因为营销人员不认为人们会购买让他们痛苦的产品。他们认为人们购买的是他们喜欢并能让他们快乐的产品。父母们喜欢讲述他们小时候的故事。这被称为“怀旧”。
I had a tonka truck. I'm an attached catch kid. I always love dogs. And McDonald's hamburger, happy meal would give you that nostalgic feeling. The summer that summers from here on will be compared to. Or memories will be forged into the sand, and then hung on a wall for years to come. If you give people a list of products, things like movies, or music, or automobiles,
我有一个吨卡卡车。我是个“Attached Catch”的孩子。我一直很喜欢狗。麦当劳的开心乐园餐会给你那种怀旧的感觉。从今往后的夏天都将与此相提并论。或者记忆会被铸入沙滩，然后在未来的岁月里挂在墙上。如果你给人们一份产品清单，比如电影、音乐或汽车，
people tend to have a preference for the products that were popular during their youth. And so people have this natural attraction to things from their past, was how this got started. And then, yeah, they started to look at, well, if that's true, then inducing that feeling, that connection to the past,
人们往往更偏爱他们年轻时流行的产品。所以人们对过去的事物有一种天然的吸引力，这就是一切的开始。然后，是的，他们开始研究，如果这是真的，那么诱发那种感觉，那种与过去的联系，
should increase favorability towards products. I wanna take you back to a time a few years ago when your daughter was just starting high school. Like many parents, you felt proud, but you also felt some distress because your baby girl was growing up. Can you tell me what happened next? My immediate response was a little bit existential dread
应该会增加对产品的好感度。我想带你回到几年前，当时你的女儿刚开始上高中。像许多父母一样，你感到自豪，但也感到一些不安，因为你的宝贝女儿长大了。你能告诉我接下来发生了什么吗？我最初的反应是有一点存在主义的恐惧，
to be honest. It's like, where did all this time go? How am I, how do I already have a daughter that's got to be ready for my high school? But then I subsequently went through and ran all the great memories we've had with her. And then I felt more, you know, happy. I felt more of a sense of meaning and accomplishment that, oh, this is an important ride of passage and no things
老实说。就像，这些时间都去哪儿了？我怎么会已经有一个准备上高中的女儿了？但随后我回顾并重温了我们和她在一起的所有美好回忆。然后我感到更多的是，你知道，快乐。我感到更多的是一种意义感和成就感，哦，这是一个重要的人生阶段，事情
are going to be good. And so I had this experience, such as it's very common, which is a little bit of loss, but then the sense of reflection and then more of a I kind of stabilize emotionally. Clay has unlimited a study of nostalgia to his own brain. He studied the minds of other people. He once conducted an experiment where he tried to put volunteers into different kinds of moods. Some volunteers read about cute polar bears, which was supposed to elevate their mood. Others read a neutral article about the solar system. Of course to some of us is kind of cool but it's not the type of thing that gets most people super excited. A third group of volunteers read about the victims of a terrible tsunami. The idea was to put them in a negative mood. This last group of volunteers reported the
会好起来的。所以我有了这种经历，这非常普遍，有一点失落感，但随后是一种反思，然后我情绪上变得更加稳定。克莱将怀旧研究应用到了他自己的大脑上。他研究了其他人的思想。他曾经做过一个实验，试图让志愿者进入不同的情绪状态。一些志愿者阅读关于可爱北极熊的内容，这旨在提升他们的情绪。其他人阅读了一篇关于太阳系的中性文章。当然，对我们中的一些人来说这很酷，但这不是那种能让大多数人超级兴奋的事情。第三组志愿者阅读了关于可怕海啸受害者的内容。其目的是让他们陷入负面情绪。这最后一组志愿者报告了
highest levels of nostalgia. Now it's important to note that, I mean, this doesn't mean that negative emotions are the only thing that triggered nostalgia. In fact, we know as the marketing researchers have done that you can instigate nostalgia very directly with stimuli that remind people of the past, like familiar smells or sights or music. So there's this whole sensory and social type of stimuli that directly trigger nostalgia. But what we've found fascinating with this emotion research
最高水平的怀旧感。现在需要注意的是，这并不意味着负面情绪是触发怀旧的唯一因素。事实上，正如营销研究人员所做的那样，我们知道你可以通过提醒人们过去的刺激物，如熟悉的味道、景象或音乐，直接激发怀旧感。所以，有一整套感官和社会类型的刺激直接触发怀旧。但我们在这种情绪研究中发现令人着迷的是，
is that there seems to be a class of triggers that are about negative events or life experiences or emotions that appear to motivate nostalgia for more of what we call compensatory reason or psychological reasons that are about regulating distress. In other words, psychological defense. Yes, correct. Now, you and others have found that nostalgia is extremely common, very, very widespread, but I think a lot of people don't stop to think very carefully about the details of what constitutes a nostalgic memory or a nostalgic experience. And I want to try and do that in the next couple of minutes, and I want you to actually tell me
似乎有一类触发因素是关于负面事件、生活经历或情绪的，它们似乎出于我们所说的补偿性原因或心理原因来激发怀旧，这些原因与调节痛苦有关。换句话说，心理防御。是的，没错。现在，你和其他人发现怀旧是非常普遍的，非常非常广泛，但我认为很多人并没有停下来仔细思考构成怀旧记忆或怀旧体验的细节。我想在接下来的几分钟里尝试这样做，我想让你亲自告诉我
about a picture that you keep on your desk that shows you standing with your wife and two kids in front of a mural in London. Describe the photo to me and then give me a play-by-play account of what images and memories the photograph produces in your mind. Are you aware of this band, Gorillas? So in London, at least when we lived there, you know, on the South Bank, they had this really cool art that, so Gorilla's just kind of, they have this graphic novel style art associated with their music. And so they had these murals that were just kind of neat.
关于你桌上放着的一张照片，照片显示你和你的妻子以及两个孩子站在伦敦的一幅壁画前。请向我描述这张照片，然后逐一讲述这张照片在你脑海中产生的图像和记忆。你知道“街头霸王”（Gorillaz）这个乐队吗？在伦敦，至少当我们住在那里时，你知道，在南岸，他们有这种非常酷的艺术，街头霸王乐队的音乐伴随着这种图形小说风格的艺术。所以他们有这些壁画，看起来很不错。
They look very, you know, animated and comic book-y. And so there's this picture of us, you know, standing there in the South Bank. Our daughter must have been around six and her son must have been around four or five. What this picture really means to me personally is here we were, it was, you know, we were poor, we didn't have really any material possessions at the time because we were in grad school. So it seemed like there was nothing to lose. And so you have this picture that in many ways I think encapsulates that. And that's I think what's so powerful and part about nostalgia is you have these snapshots
它们看起来非常，你知道，动画化和漫画感。所以有一张我们站在南岸的照片。我女儿当时一定在六岁左右，我儿子一定在四五岁左右。这张照片对我个人而言真正的意义在于，当时我们很穷，因为我们在读研究生，所以当时没有任何物质财富。所以似乎没有什么可失去的。所以你拥有的这张照片在很多方面我认为都概括了这一点。我认为这就是怀旧如此强大的部分原因，你拥有这些
of your life that capture these very, very rich and complex memories, the stories about yourself. And that one really to me is like, here we are, we've got these small kids, we moved to England, we don't know anyone there and we're having this great adventure and it's an adventure for my wife and I, but it's also an adventure for our kids and for the whole family. So there are a couple of things about this memory that stand out to me, and I think they're revealing about what your research and other research has shown about nostalgia. First of all, there is this bittersweet element to your memory of that day. I mean, you're recalling the fact, for example, that you were poor, that you were dealing with small kids,
你生活中的快照，捕捉到了这些非常、非常丰富和复杂的记忆，关于你自己的故事。那一张对我来说真的是，我们在这里，我们有这些小孩，我们搬到了英国，我们在那里谁也不认识，我们正在经历这场伟大的冒险，这对我和我妻子来说是一场冒险，但对我们的孩子和整个家庭来说也是一场冒险。所以关于这段记忆有几件事让我印象深刻，我认为它们揭示了你的研究和其他研究关于怀旧所展示的内容。首先，你对那一天的记忆中有一种苦乐参半的成分。我的意思是，你回想起这样一个事实，例如，你当时很穷，你在照顾小孩，
that you didn't have any friends that you knew in London. So, there are elements of the story that someone could hear and say, this is a story of sadness and loss, but it's also as you're telling it to me, this is also a story about a moment of family triumph, something that brought the family together. And I want you to talk about this idea that nostalgia has these two strains simultaneously, something that feels sad, but something that feels triumphant and happy as well. One of the things that I found very interesting about this research in nostalgia is you have these very complex emotional experiences
你在伦敦一个认识的朋友都没有。所以，故事中确实有一些元素，别人听了可能会说，这是一个关于悲伤和失落的故事，但正如你告诉我的那样，这也是一个关于家庭胜利时刻的故事，一些让家庭团结在一起的事情。我想让你谈谈这个观点，即怀旧同时具有这两种特质，一种感觉悲伤，但同时也感觉胜利和快乐。我在怀旧研究中发现非常有趣的一点是，你拥有这些非常复杂的情绪体验，
often involve involving great hardship and loss and struggle. But also as you noted, there seems to be some kind of redemptive nature to them, or triumphant nature to them. In fact, some of the best nostalgic memories that we've collected were from when I was in England and we were doing this research as we had a sample of older adults and these were these were older British adults who had you know where were alive and were children most of them during World War II when Germany was bombing Great Britain. There are 279,000 children still in London. Many are bombed out of their homes, all looked hard, but they feel safe here. A good hundred feet below ground and their spirit and fortitude are simply grand.
通常涉及巨大的困难、失落和挣扎。但正如你所指出的，它们似乎也有一种救赎的本质，或者说胜利的本质。事实上，我们收集到的一些最好的怀旧记忆来自我在英国做这项研究的时候，我们有一个老年人样本，这些是年长的英国人，他们经历过，或者说在二战期间，当德国轰炸英国时，他们中的大多数人还是孩子。伦敦仍有279,000名儿童。许多人的家被炸毁，生活艰难，但他们在这里感到安全。在地下一百英尺深处，他们的精神和毅力简直太棒了。
And a lot of these people had these nostalgic memories about serious family upheaval. Their dad being sent away to war, then being sent to the countryside because London was being bombed. Families being separated. And on the one hand, you could say, these are really, really bad, traumatic memories. But in nearly all of these memories
这些人中的许多人都有关于严重家庭动荡的怀旧记忆。他们的父亲被送去打仗，然后因为伦敦遭到轰炸，他们被送往乡村。家庭被分离。一方面，你可以说，这些是非常、非常糟糕的创伤性记忆。但在几乎所有这些记忆中，
that people wrote about for us, they had this experience of triumph, of gratefulness, of thankfulness for these times, because on the one hand they were tough, but they also sort of stripped away all the nonsense of life and reminded them how precious it is and what's really important in terms of their family and their meaningful connections. And so I feel like this often happens a lot in nostalgia, is you really start to get at the core of what people find personally valuable and meaningful. And a lot of times
人们为我们写下的，他们都有这种胜利、感激、对这些时光心存谢意的体验，因为一方面它们很艰难，但它们也剥离了生活中所有无意义的东西，提醒他们生活是多么珍贵，以及在家庭和有意义的联系方面什么是真正重要的。所以我感觉这在怀旧中经常发生，你真的开始触及人们认为个人有价值和有意义的核心。很多时候，
that means suffering or loss or hardship. So I think what I'm hearing you say in some ways is that nostalgia might involve some amount of rewriting of the past. So, you know, we're seeing ourselves in some ways as the central protagonist of this movie. We're seeing, you know, the struggles and challenges we experience, but also the triumphs and the ways we overcame those challenges. And in some ways these are, the journalist and me would say that this might be misremembering the way things actually happened. But of course, a psychologist would say, this is exactly what all human beings need to do. We need to remember the kinds of things that we went through and we want to tell ourselves stories about the kind of people we are and how we became this way.
这意味着痛苦、失落或困难。所以我认为我听到你说的在某种程度上是，怀旧可能涉及一定程度的对过去的重写。所以，你知道，我们在某种程度上把自己看作这部电影的核心主角。我们看到，你知道，我们经历的挣扎和挑战，但也看到了胜利以及我们克服这些挑战的方式。在某种程度上，作为记者的我会说这可能是对事情实际发生方式的错误记忆。但当然，心理学家会说，这正是所有人类需要做的。我们需要记住我们经历过的事情，我们想告诉自己关于我们是什么样的人以及我们是如何变成今天这个样子的故事。
And some rewriting of history, some recollection of the facts that suits our image of who we are today is what produces these nostalgic images. To me, it's almost like making a movie. You have all these memories that represent raw footage, right, of all the filming that you've done. And of course, anyone who's seen him who's made a movie or watched a movie knows you don't go watch hundreds of hours of raw footage. That would be a horrible movie, right?
而对历史的一些重写，对符合我们今天形象的事实的一些回忆，正是产生这些怀旧图像的原因。对我来说，这几乎就像制作一部电影。你拥有所有代表原始素材的记忆，对吧，你拍摄的所有片段。当然，任何看过电影或制作过电影的人都知道，你不会去看数百小时的原始素材。那将是一部糟糕的电影，对吧？
You have an editing process, a process where the director and editors and people involved with the film will sort of shape and edit the movie in a way that tells the story that they want to tell or that features the most central themes in a narrative and a meaningful way. And we do that to some extent with our autobiographical memories as well. So it's not the case that we're necessarily completely fabricating memories so much as we're selecting and kind of weaving these different memories into a meaningful self-narrative that helps us make some sense of our lives and our connection to others. Now this doesn't mean it can't go wrong or that people don't have false memories, but I think a decent portion of this is healthy recollection that's
你有一个剪辑过程，一个导演、剪辑师和参与电影的人会以一种讲述他们想要讲述的故事，或者以一种有意义的方式突出叙事中最核心主题的方式来塑造和剪辑电影。我们在某种程度上也用我们的自传体记忆做同样的事情。所以，并不是说我们一定在完全捏造记忆，更多的是我们在选择并将这些不同的记忆编织成一个有意义的自我叙事，帮助我们理解我们的生活以及我们与他人的联系。现在，这并不意味着它不会出错，或者人们不会有虚假记忆，但我认为其中很大一部分是健康的记忆，
not necessarily false, but does involve a certain level of massaging their footage, so to speak. When we come back, I'm going to talk to Clay about the effects of nostalgia. Is it a force for good or a force for bad? And I'm going to ask him about one of the most nostalgia-invoking presidential campaigns in recent history. We will make America great again. Stay with us. When Johannes Hauffer came up with the word nostalgia over 300 years ago, he thought of nostalgia as a brain disease of demonic cause. But clear atlages found that nostalgia may actually be good for us.
不一定是虚假的，但确实涉及一定程度的“按摩”素材，可以这么说。回来后，我将和克莱谈谈怀旧的影响。它是一种向善的力量还是一种向恶的力量？我还要问他关于近代史上最能唤起怀旧之情的总统竞选之一。我们将让美国再次伟大。请留下来。当约翰内斯·霍弗在300多年前提出“怀旧”这个词时，他认为怀旧是一种由恶魔引起的脑部疾病。但克莱·拉特利奇发现，怀旧实际上可能对我们有好处。
Yes, if you look within what we would refer to as normal populations, so these are research participants that don't have any particular vulnerability that might distinguish, you know, the way they Recollect on the past which you find as nostalgia seems to be generally a net positive Experience that has a whole host of psychological benefits. I Suppose it's possible for people to argue, you know, if you spend excessive amounts of time I suppose it's possible for people to argue, you know, if you spend excessive amounts of time, ruminating about the past and living in the past, this could also be bad for you. I mean, isn't it possible that people who are spending huge amounts of time in the past? In some ways, I think your research and other people's research is suggesting, if distress
是的，如果你看看我们所说的正常人群，也就是那些没有特别脆弱性、可能区分他们回忆过去方式的研究参与者，你会发现怀旧通常是一种净正面的体验，具有许多心理益处。我想人们可能会争论，你知道，如果你花费过多的时间，我想人们可能会争论，你知道，如果你花费过多的时间，沉思过去并活在过去，这可能对你也有害。我的意思是，难道那些花费大量时间在过去的人，
causes people to become nostalgic, then people who are excessively nostalgic, could they not be people who are experiencing high levels of distress? Yes, I mean, in fact, we find that that characteristics like loneliness, so loneliness, which we all experience from time to time, but it's also a trait, like some people tend to be more lonely than others, are associated with nostalgia as is neuroticism. So these negative emotional traits tend to be associated with nostalgia, but there's also a reason to suspect that these experiences in nostalgia are helping people restore some sense of psychological well-being while people are experiencing these emotions.
在某种程度上，我认为你的研究和其他人的研究表明，如果痛苦导致人们变得怀旧，那么过度怀旧的人，难道不可能是那些正在经历高水平痛苦的人吗？是的，我的意思是，事实上，我们发现孤独等特征，也就是我们时不时都会经历的孤独，但它也是一种特质，就像有些人往往比其他人更孤独一样，与怀旧有关，神经质也是如此。所以这些负面情绪特质往往与怀旧有关，但也有理由怀疑，这些怀旧体验正在帮助人们在经历这些情绪时恢复某种心理健康感。
Besides being an expert on nostalgically, you've spent a lot of time advocating for greater ideological diversity in the social sciences. You've made the case that more conservative voices need to be part of the conversation. I'd like to try and connect these two parts of your life, the researcher who studies nostalgia on the one hand and the person who's interested in conservative thought on the other hand, and I want to do it by talking about the 2016 presidential campaign of Donald Trump. Lots of presidential campaigns talk about the future. They talk about how changes coming about, hope for the future. But Donald Trump, very specifically, turned his attention toward the past. He invoked a sense of nostalgia among followers, and he
除了是怀旧专家外，你还花了很多时间倡导社会科学中更大的意识形态多样性。你提出需要让更多的保守派声音参与对话。我想尝试连接你生活中的这两个部分，一方面是研究怀旧的研究人员，另一方面是对保守思想感兴趣的人，我想通过谈论唐纳德·特朗普2016年的总统竞选来做到这一点。许多总统竞选都谈论未来。他们谈论变革即将到来，对未来的希望。但唐纳德·特朗普非常具体地将注意力转向了过去。他在追随者中唤起了一种怀旧感，他
communicated the idea that America had seen brighter days and both he and his followers felt that they wanted to make America great again. I'm wondering whether the science of nostalgia has any insights into the appeal of Donald Trump and the success of his presidential campaign? Well I think one thing that's important to distinguish is the difference between what we might call personal nostalgia and historical or some people call Collectiveness, D'Alge. Now a lot of the work that I've done or I get nearly all the work I've done and pretty much everything We've talked about thus far is about this idea of personal nostalgia, which is us revisiting memories from our own which is us revisiting memories from our own past, our own childhood or youth or whenever.
传达了美国曾有过更美好日子的想法，他和他的追随者都觉得他们想让美国再次伟大。我想知道怀旧科学对唐纳德·特朗普的吸引力以及他总统竞选的成功是否有任何见解？我认为重要的一点是区分我们可能称之为“个人怀旧”和“历史怀旧”（有些人称之为集体怀旧）。我所做的大部分工作，或者说我几乎所有的工作，以及我们到目前为止谈论的几乎所有内容，都是关于这种“个人怀旧”的想法，也就是我们重温自己过去的记忆，我们自己的童年或青年时期，或者其他时候。
Like these are our personal memories. And that seems to be distinct from this more historical nostalgia, which you can imagine having nostalgic feelings for a period of time or for an idea that you never actually had any direct contact with. So there are people, you know, to step outside of politics for just a second. There are people that have nostalgia for the 1920s. They just think everything about from the architecture to the fashion, that everything's great, and they never lived in that time.
就像这些是我们个人的记忆。这似乎与这种更具历史性的怀旧不同，你可以想象对一个你从未真正有过直接接触的时期或想法产生怀旧感。所以有些人，你知道，暂时跳出政治话题。有些人对20世纪20年代有怀旧之情。他们只是认为从建筑到时尚的一切都很棒，而他们从未生活在那个时代。
And so they can't really trace it to a personal or autobiographical experience. And so I think that's important. What Trump seems to have done either by design or by just stumbling onto it was really latch on to this idea of historic nostalgia that there's some kind of collective feeling of nostalgia that's beyond any individual experience that of feeling of nostalgia that's beyond any individual experience that was about a time that perhaps was at least for some, in their mind, imagine that was better. Now, of course, that doesn't mean that it was. What matters is that he sold the idea. I have to say, when I was young in high school and college, everybody used to say, we never
所以他们无法真正将其追溯到个人或自传体的经历。所以我认为这很重要。特朗普似乎所做的，无论是出于设计还是仅仅是偶然发现，确实抓住了这种“历史怀旧”的想法，即存在某种超越任何个人经历的集体怀旧感，关于一个在某些人心中想象中可能更好的时代。当然，这并不意味着它真的更好。重要的是他推销了这个想法。我必须说，当我年轻在高中和大学时，每个人都说，我们从未
lost a war. We never lost a war. We never lost a war, you remember? You know what I hate? There's a guy totally disruptive, throwing punches. We're not allowed to punch back anymore. I love the old days, you know what they used to do to guys like that when they were in a place like this. They'd be carried out on a stretcher, folks.
输过一场战争。我们从未输过一场战争。我们从未输过一场战争，你记得吗？你知道我讨厌什么吗？有个家伙完全具有破坏性，到处挥拳。我们不再被允许反击了。我喜欢过去的日子，你知道他们过去是怎么对待像那样的人的，当他们在像这样的地方时。他们会被担架抬出去，伙计们。
when they were in a place like this, they'd be carried out on a stretcher, folks. Yeah. You know, I'd also add that it's not specific to Trump, though that's, you know, clearly the most recent example from our culture, but there's actually, you know, people that have looked into Soviet era nostalgia, that there are people in Eastern Europe and Russia that have nostalgia for the Soviet Union,
当他们在像这样的地方时，他们会被担架抬出去，伙计们。是的。你知道，我还要补充一点，这并不是特朗普特有的，尽管这显然是我们文化中最近的例子，但实际上，你知道，有人研究过苏联时代的怀旧，东欧和俄罗斯有人对苏联怀旧，
even if they were too young to really fully understand what was going on that time. So this idea of historical nostalgia is definitely its own kind of beast, and I don't feel like as far as the science of it, we really have a full handle on it yet. So obviously it's much harder to study collective nostalgia and shared nostalgia than it is to study individual nostalgia. You know, you can't bring countries into your lab and evaluate millions of people.
即使他们太年轻，无法真正完全理解当时发生了什么。所以这种“历史怀旧”的想法绝对有它自己的特点，我不觉得就其科学性而言，我们真的完全掌握了它。所以显然，研究集体怀旧和共享怀旧比研究个人怀旧要困难得多。你知道，你不能把国家带进你的实验室并评估数百万人。
But is it possible that at a collective level nostalgia performs the same function that it does at an individual level? Yeah, I think that's a reasonable hypothesis. For example, people have noted that at the time of the following the economic recession in the United States, you saw this peak kind of interest in nostalgia products, whether it was reboots of movie. On Friday, Batman returns again.
但有没有可能在集体层面上，怀旧发挥着与个人层面相同的功能？是的，我认为这是一个合理的假设。例如，人们注意到在美国经济衰退之后，你看到了对怀旧产品的兴趣激增，无论是电影的重启。周五，蝙蝠侠再次回归。
The Dark Knight, once again, stars Christian Bayley. Those types of cultural consumption products. Now, these aren't experiments, of course. And they're not even really scientific. They're in the sense that don't one try to systematically study this. But there was some acknowledgement that it seems like in times of collective people,
《黑暗骑士》，再次由克里斯蒂安·贝尔主演。这类文化消费产品。当然，这些不是实验。它们甚至不是真正的科学。它们不是那种试图系统地研究这一点的人。但确实有一些承认，似乎在集体动荡时期，
just like times of personal people, people seem to turn more into nostalgic feelings. So I think that's certainly a reasonable possibility. We talked earlier in our conversations about how recollections of our past might not necessarily be fabrications, but they are selective edits in some ways of our history. So, you have that photograph on your desk, if you're standing with your family in front of the London mural, and you remember the good parts of that history and your story.
就像个人动荡时期一样，人们似乎更多地转向了怀旧情绪。所以我认为这当然是一个合理的可能性。我们在之前的谈话中讨论过，我们对过去的记忆可能不一定是捏造的，但它们在某种程度上是我们历史的选择性编辑。所以，你桌上有那张照片，如果你和你的家人站在伦敦的壁画前，你记得那段历史和你的故事中好的部分。
You don't necessarily remember that maybe that morning, maybe you weren't the best dad that you could have been. Maybe you were impatient or you were shot tempered. I mean, you don't remember that part of it. You remember just the fact that you were facing a challenge with your family and you were on a big adventure. And I'm wondering, is the same thing possibly true at a collective level as well, which is, you know, we have these nostalgic memories, but is it possible there's an element of
你不一定记得那天早上，也许你不是你能做的最好的父亲。也许你很不耐烦或脾气暴躁。我的意思是，你不记得那部分了。你只记得你和家人面临挑战并且正在进行一场大冒险的事实。我想知道，在集体层面上是否也可能存在同样的情况，即，你知道，我们有这些怀旧记忆，但有没有可能其中有一个元素
them that really is insidious, especially at a cultural level? When you see the debate over Confederate memorials, for example, and the nostalgia that people feel over Confederate memorials, many people will say this is tradition and this is nostalgia, and there are equally many people on the other side who say, you're remembering a history that essentially has whitewashed, you know, the issue of slavery or the issue of race relationships from that memory and replaced it with this relatively grand and benign idea of tradition. How would you respond to that? Yeah, I think that's a fair point, even with example of personal nostalgia.
确实是阴险的，特别是在文化层面上？例如，当你看到关于邦联纪念碑的辩论，以及人们对邦联纪念碑感到的怀旧时，许多人会说这是传统，这是怀旧，而另一方也有同样多的人说，你记住的是一段本质上粉饰了奴隶制问题或种族关系问题的历史，并用这种相对宏大且良性的传统观念取而代之。你会如何回应这一点？是的，我认为这是一个合理的观点，即使在个人怀旧的例子中也是如此。
Nostalgia can be a source of inspiration and a stabilizing force as well, but you shouldn't let it blind you or shouldn't be the only dimension through which you think about these issues, because you're absolutely right. It's part of our psychological immune system to more easily forget the negative
怀旧也可以是灵感的来源和稳定的力量，但你不应该让它蒙蔽你的双眼，或者不应该成为你思考这些问题的唯一维度，因为你是绝对正确的。这是我们心理免疫系统的一部分，更容易忘记过去的负面
features of the past, either through this sort of revisionist process that you mentioned, or even through just natural recollection. I mean, a lot of negative memories fade from, you know, our awareness faster than positive memories, and this seems to be adaptive for us personally moving forward in life, but it also biases us towards, you know, not necessarily doing a good job of thinking about the complexities of the whole picture and thinking about other people's experiences, which may be giving the Confederate example vastly different than our own. And so I do think that, thoughahlja certainly has a number of positive benefits
特征，无论是通过你提到的这种修正主义过程，还是仅仅通过自然的回忆。我的意思是，许多负面记忆比正面记忆更快地从我们的意识中消失，这对于我们个人在生活中继续前行似乎是适应性的，但它也使我们产生偏见，不一定能很好地思考整个图景的复杂性，也不一定能思考其他人的经历，这可能使邦联的例子与我们自己的经历大不相同。所以我确实认为，虽然怀旧肯定有许多积极的益处，
that we shouldn't let ourselves be intoxicated by Nostalgia because there are some real dangers associated with that. Claire and I wrapped up our conversation by talking about what he said was the most surprising finding about Nostalgia. Nostalgia seems to actually orient people towards the future. And so part of what seems to be going on is you experience some kind of distress, which kind of makes you shrink a little bit from pursuing goals and from the future. Like it does kick you into more of this defensive mode. And then you bring to mind these nostalgic experiences that they don't only make you feel good, we now have evidence that they actually make you feel optimistic and hopeful about the future.
我们不应该让自己沉溺于怀旧，因为这确实存在一些相关的真正危险。克莱和我通过谈论他所说的关于怀旧最令人惊讶的发现结束了我们的谈话。怀旧似乎实际上引导人们走向未来。所以似乎正在发生的一部分是，你经历某种痛苦，这让你在追求目标和未来方面有点退缩。就像它确实把你踢进了这种防御模式。然后你回想起这些怀旧体验，它们不仅让你感觉良好，我们现在有证据表明它们实际上让你对未来感到乐观和充满希望。
And so that in turn seems to mobilize people, particularly in the social domain. And now we have a number of studies that show this both in terms of people reporting that they're more optimistic about the future, more inspired, but also behaviorally too, in terms of people actually going out and wanting to interact with and meet people after they've engaged in nostalgia. So at one level actually this is surprising, but as you're talking just now, I realize this also makes perfect sense. I mean, people are nostalgic in every culture, and as far as we can tell, have always, you know, all historical reports suggest that nostalgia is very widespread. And when you see something that's
所以这反过来似乎动员了人们，特别是在社会领域。现在我们有许多研究表明这一点，无论是在人们报告说他们对未来更乐观、更受启发方面，还是在行为上，在人们在参与怀旧后实际上走出去并想要与人互动和见面方面。所以在一个层面上这确实令人惊讶，但正如你刚才所说，我意识到这也完全说得通。我的意思是，人们在每种文化中都会怀旧，据我们所知，一直以来，所有历史报告都表明怀旧非常普遍。当你看到像
as widespread as nostalgia seems to be, it's reasonable to draw the conclusion this is performing some kind of adaptive function and not just helping people feel better, but in actually being able to function better. And nostalgia has had this historically had this stigma, as we talked about it, it started out very much as being considered a disease. And people even today, a lot of people will say, well, I'm not nostalgic because I think about the future. I'm not the type of person that likes to fixate or get stuck in the past.
怀旧这样普遍的东西时，得出结论认为它正在发挥某种适应性功能是合理的，不仅是帮助人们感觉更好，而且实际上能够更好地运作。怀旧在历史上一直有这种污名，正如我们所讨论的，它最初被认为是一种疾病。即使在今天，很多人仍然会说，嗯，我不怀旧，因为我思考的是未来。我不是那种喜欢固执己见或困在过去的人。
And I think what they're missing when they say that is, there is a big element of nostalgia that isn't about us retreating to the past. It's about us pulling the past forward to the present and using it to mobilize us, to energize us, to take on new challenges and opportunities. Claire Rutledge is a psychology professor at Not Dakota State University. He's the author of nostalgia, a psychological resource. Clay, thank you for
我认为当他们那样说时，他们错过的是，怀旧中有一个很大的部分不是关于我们退回到过去。它是关于我们将过去拉向现在，并利用它来动员我们，激励我们，去迎接新的挑战和机遇。克莱·拉特利奇是北达科他州立大学的心理学教授。他是《怀旧：一种心理资源》一书的作者。克莱，谢谢你
joining me today on Hidden Breath. Thank you for having me. This episode was produced by Reina Cohen. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman, Parts Shah and Renee Clarre. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Our unsung hero this week is Tommy O'Keefe. Tommy is a programmer who works on the technical side of NPR's website and he was on call late one night recently when we were having problems publishing our podcast. We couldn't figure out why the audio wasn't showing up in the podcast feed and to put it mildly, we were starting to freak out. Tommy quickly figured out what the problem was and fixed it. That would have been more than enough to win our gratitude, but we were impressed by his bedside manner. He fixed the problem while chit chatting about other
今天加入《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你邀请我。本集由雷娜·科恩制作。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼、帕茨·沙和蕾妮·克莱尔。我们的监制是塔拉·博伊尔。我们本周的无名英雄是汤米·奥基夫。汤米是一名程序员，负责NPR网站的技术方面，最近有一天深夜，当我们遇到发布播客的问题时，他正在值班。我们无法弄清楚为什么音频没有出现在播客源中，委婉地说，我们开始抓狂了。汤米很快弄清楚了问题所在并修复了它。这足以赢得我们的感激，但我们对他处理问题的方式印象深刻。他在闲聊其他
stuff. In other words, he held our hand. Thanks Tommy, we have your number on speed dial for the next crisis. For more hidden brain, please follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram. I'm Shakir Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
事情的同时解决了问题。换句话说，他安抚了我们。谢谢你，汤米，我们把你的号码存在了快速拨号里，以备下次危机。想了解更多《Hidden Brain》，请在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。